last to play bryson d first time
at the match the 2020 u.s open champion
eight time tour winner
go get him bryson
oh yeah oh my god
i think that's okay there i think you
might be too close erin
i think you might be too close i didn't
i think it got over 30-yard little
up and down i'm not sure
[Music]
yes sir oh maybe go in hey out of the
gates
right there baby just lay up to there
that's all we do
nice layout teamwork is for the win
so we got a 392 yard hole bryson scaling
back to some kind of fairway wood
yeah i would have thought he'd be going
for the green on this one oh he is i
think he is mr president
yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
right there wow and getting better
uh i i just want you to know trevor my
three-wood goes just as far
that's unbelievable i'll take that
partner thanks
that's screaming right on the good line
again come on
good shot oh you kind of followed my
lead
keep an eye on it doing the same thing
oh my goodness
sorry about that i'm telling you i'm
talking about
that
come on ball hook come on open that wind
a little bit come on that's a good shot
yeah he's a good shot
he's right in that area we talked about
yeah
i think i did it oh you more than did it
that is amazing
good heavens seriously
that's going to hit the downslope
oh man adjust it just down correct i'll
adjust it fractionally right here on the
spot a little more like chest this is a
little more like uh
perfect perfect you started at about
seven inches outside
you're right joe catch that slope
yeah good shot come on ball come on come
on buddy come on
keep doing your thing come on yeah
getting better come on bull that's a
gimme good shot
if you make it at this point i think we
win the match
uh-oh go in
oh it's gotta be close there we go it's
coming back off that slope here we go
i don't know if it's gonna come back or
not wow good one